[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum hi Ryan hello hello my
voice cracked a little bit so he's
trying to see her at the end Peter Brady
over here Jesus it's an old reference uh
you know I just did something really
interesting and we'll get back we'll get
into the interview which is a really fun
interview today
but uh there's this place called pronuvo
and they have these scans these body
scans that detect like first stage early
cancers and a bunch of other stuff they
test like everything except leukemia or
something they can detect so you take
this body scan and it pretty much it's
like this new preemptive technological
advance in medicine or whatever but it's
this full body scan and prenuvo does it
so I said oh I want to get one of these
so I went and did it and I'm waiting for
my results but it was pretty awesome
you're there for like 45 minutes or an
hour in this like MRI thing but they put
these glasses on you and you can see you
watch Netflix I watched like three
episodes of Seinfeld and I was done
and that was it and it was easy and um
but it could save people's lives and I
was like why don't I jump on this maybe
if there's something wrong I could fix
it Seinfeld is saving people's lives is
what you're saying I'm still the Savior
that's what I got out of this but um
like look I'm not getting paid for this
but it's obviously a great thing uh if
you want to do it just go Um in fact you
can go to pronuvo
p-r-e-n-u-v-o.com slash Michael and
you'll get a 300 discount
pronuvo.com Michael I thought it was
really cool and I can't wait to read my
results but it's you know I'm I'm not a
hypochondriac but if I could if somebody
can detect something before it became
serious if I had something isn't that
what you want yeah if a doctor says hey
your bill of health is great but if the
doctor instead said hey your bill of
health is it's great right now is great
you do have this one concern it's not
really a concern right now but it could
be a concern later so you could handle
it now if you'd like
wouldn't that be better news
yes I mean rather than do it later
rather than maybe not being able to
handle it then anyway
um great guess in the podcast I've known
this lady this woman for a while she's a
animal rights activist she saves
so many animals
um she doesn't even live here anymore
she um as much as she still loves acting
she still does a lot of other things and
uh this is going to be a really cool
show I like how she opens up but she I
mean like she's like saving rhinoceros
and you say rhinoceroses I was the
rhinoceride you know I should know
I didn't know you should as one who's
frequently referred to by nickname as
rhino rhino oh yeah you should
definitely know that I don't um anyway
uh it's a it's a great episode
um just a few things
um what what are a few things thanks for
everybody coming out to Dallas this last
weekend it was a blast I had a great
time loved doing the Smallville nights
for you and um if you want to go to the
inside of you online store get cool
merch there's tons of stuff there check
it inside of you online store and um
there's also sunspin.com you can get
band merch from the band our CDs out
other cool swag you could listen to us
anywhere streaming for free love for you
to have a listen to the band uh sunspin
and follow us of course at sunspin band
and also at
inside you podcast on Facebook and
Instagram and all that and write a
review for the podcast if you like it
always helps all that stuff and uh last
but not least patreon um thank you
patrons for supporting the podcast
um
really helps without you guys I would be
doing the podcast patreon.com inside you
and there's a lot of cool perks and I
think you'll really dig being a patron
um a lot of friendships have evolved on
this right on the patreon yeah yeah and
everyone is very nice everyone's
organized some people send gifts to you
like you to me yeah it's you know it's
uh great folks I love the top tier
um for the for the patreon they get a
box from me every few months
and I signed a note and I'm like I feel
like I know these people now some have
been around for years and I'm like oh my
God okay aspo what's up despo Ross
what's up you know it's like I've known
these people and they've stuck with the
podcast and it's just amazing that I get
so much support so I really appreciate
that
and um that's it if you know any good
horror movies let me know shoot me a
tweet tell me to watch something because
everything I see is [__] absolute [__] I
mean almost everything I watch is just
Dreadful
there were a couple things you were
raving about recently well it wasn't the
menu
well the menu is not a horror movie um I
know I didn't hate the menu I just
didn't love it I thought it was like
overrated it was like the first 30
minutes you're like oh this is great and
then that second half of it was just I
don't know
yeah
um
I never saw it yeah well you don't have
to yeah but uh
anyway let's get into it let's get
inside of Shannon Elizabeth it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you with Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you saved peanut
that's all you do is save animals that's
pretty much your life yeah that's that's
my mission is animals so yeah it's it's
crazy I used to have my animal rescue
animal Avengers so the charity now is a
just a changed version of that where we
do bigger animals right the Shannon
Elizabeth Foundation right
yeah look at peanut Peanut's so sweet
it's amazing it will get to this because
first of all thank you for doing this
it's so cool you're in Cape Town
South Africa you're how many hours ahead
you are oh let me figure it out because
I'm not good with math if it's 10 a.m
here it's it's nine hours
it's not you're nine hours ahead
did you have a long day are you tired
you look refreshed you look very good
um it's it's really hot here right now
it's very windy outside
um I picked up my husband from the
hospital today because he'd hurt his arm
he was in the hospital overnight
two nights what happened to him
he he was actually in here I just
brought him food
and he had
given him a knife that I'll never give
him again because it was just a bit
sharper
um to cut something and he stood up and
he slipped on a scarf that was on the
floor and the knife went into his
forearm
you can't even make it up like this
forearm and it cut his tendon like the
tendon that keeps your hand from doing
this from moving around flopping from
one side to the other so he couldn't do
they couldn't move it
he could move his fingers at first he
couldn't and then as he was there for a
while he realized he could move his
fingers
but um but he knew that that part wasn't
working and they wanted a surgeon to
come in and get in there and really
check it out and they said it was worse
than they thought it was so he was was
there a lot of blood ton of blood
yeah yeah there's still Blood on the
floor here it's like everywhere did you
almost pass out or are you kind of tough
like that no no I'm tough um I went and
grabbed a towel and he said okay hold it
tight and I'm gonna pull my hand out and
um and then I ran upstairs and got like
my purse and phones and everything and
we I luckily there's a hospital about 10
minutes away so I raced him there was
the knife stuck in his arm no okay oh my
God because then I started thinking do
you pull it out what do you do right
right yeah no he said that it he thinks
it fell out right away he's not even
sure he doesn't know how it happened it
went in and out he doesn't know if it
went in and cut but it was a pretty big
cut from the photos and then the doctor
cut it open even more because he said he
didn't care about a scar he cared about
his hand working so they cut it open a
lot more to to make sure they could make
it work again oh my God so only butter
knives from now on Shannon not even he
gets a fork and a spoon
I'll cut everything I mean look we're
both vegans he didn't really need a
steak Knife we don't eat steak so how
long have you been a vegan I haven't had
meat in it's got to be close to 30 years
30 years
what would happen if you had a hamburger
right now I think I'd feel sick you'd
probably get sick after not having it
for so long right yeah I think it would
hurt my stomach do you think you feel
there's a significant or is it too long
to remember do you feel just better
being a vegan is it just do you feel
like it's healthier it's a healthier
thing you know I I'm always really torn
with it I think everyone has to explore
what's right for their body and I think
that changes over time as well I mean
for me whether it's the best thing for
my body I don't know probably not but at
this point in my life I probably need
something more than what I'm getting but
for me it's ethics I you know I I'm my
mission is to help animals and I just
can't eat one and then save another it
doesn't make sense to me right it does
so I mean I have to be this way even if
I don't want to be yeah you know but I I
mean I have good friends that are on
strict strict keto carnivore diets and
they they do great on it and you don't
judge them you don't say anything you're
like live your life
no no I I actually wanted to learn about
it for my husband's father like my
father-in-law because he needed to lose
some and I knew he wasn't going to do a
vegan diet but I thought keto is
something he could do so I started
learning about it so then I could help
teach him about it and it's working
really well for him so I think there's
something out there for everyone
everyone's body is different so you have
to do what's right for you yeah I think
I need a change I don't know if it's
becoming a vegan or whatever it is but I
think
you know I drag ass a lot maybe it's
because I'm 50 maybe because there's
some things going on I don't know but
like I I think I need to improve my diet
regardless I think that probably
you know like I just woke up and you
know a little while ago and I had a I I
had some peanut butter toast and a half
a banana that's not bad that's good
well is it regular toast uh it's
gluten-free bread
okay well that's that's a little bit
better I mean yeah a lot of carbs a lot
of people just don't do well with carbs
as they get older because carbs is what
turns to Sugar so it just depends what
your goals are you know my goals are to
have more energy Shannon I need more
energy
then stop the carbs right then don't eat
the carbs
basically there's lots of ways of doing
it it just
your
what your goal is all right well like
I'll figure it out I'll figure it out
I'll figure it out well look I want to
get into this whole animal rescue and
conservationism if that's the right word
is that the right word I think it is
I've never heard it called that but
conservationism but she's a
conservationist so wouldn't it be
conservationism
you know what guys I'm not here for an
English class
for an English lesson that's not my
thing I'm just here to educate you on
who Shannon Elizabeth is and what she
does now you have a pretty great you've
had a pretty great career and you kind
of transitioned a lot nothing I mean
you're still acting but you're you're
like you just fell in love with this you
know this whole idea of helping animals
and moving to Cape Town and and it's
just it's amazing how you've just
changed your whole life over the past
years and I want to know how you got
into it but first I want to rewind I
want to go back to Houston Texas a
little bit because you were born in
Houston you moved to Waco and the first
thing I looked at my engineer Ryan here
and the first thing we think of is like
Waco uh David koresh uh she went to Waco
High School and that's all we know I
think that's all if you ask anybody
about wake up they'll just say oh yeah
that thing that happened
so yeah obviously it's there's more to
Waco than just the the incident that
happened with David koresh but were you
a pretty happy child were you uh were
you outgoing were you popular what was
it like growing up
my perception of me in school I've found
out over the years is very different
from other people's perception of me and
everyone's gonna have a different
version of that so to me no I wasn't
popular but I was always trying to be
popular I always wanted to fit in I
wanted to have friends
um and and I would try to have friends
in like every clicky group there was
because I didn't feel like I needed to
be part of just one group so I was like
trying to be friends with everybody
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
yeah so you know if you are friends with
different people like different groups
but you get in a fight with one of your
friends then that whole group is mad at
you and it was this whole thing for me
that I just always felt like there you
know I never fit in so I would see other
people come to the school brand new and
they would instantly fit in somewhere
and I never really fit in and that was
really hard for me and I I did try out
for cheerleader
my freshman year and my senior year and
I only got it those years I only tried
out those years but I got it those years
because it was based on skill and not
popularity the other two years I didn't
try out because it was based on
popularity and I knew I wouldn't get it
wow so I did dance team and then I was a
tennis player I did competitive tennis
um
so I was constantly trying to join clubs
and be part of things and but it just
you know okay we're we're similar then
see I didn't think we had any
similarities rule I mean we do because
we like saving animals and we're like
you know I think I like to call myself
kind
kind person I think but uh but like I
felt like the same way in high school I
didn't I didn't fit in I was I'd hang
out with the goth people and I'd hang
out with some of the like some of the
popular people then I'd hang out with
the the Stoners and the the guys who
took electricity and mechanics and you
know they go out for smoke or something
and I'd hang out with them but I didn't
really fit in anywhere I didn't know who
I was I didn't really I just if you
asked people see when you talk about
perception
and people's perception of me and my
perception of myself growing up I think
that it's pretty
linear it's pretty consistent
I think people would say if you said
Michael Rosemont they'd either say I
don't who well I I remember like use
this really small weird kid
I was just like the small sort of
insecure weird kid who didn't start
puberty till late who couldn't get girls
who couldn't and people's perception
people remember that they certainly do I
think when I go home now they're like oh
you grew when did you grow and like you
know and then you became sort of famous
and then so it was just
I think everybody's perception of me was
was what I thought of myself in a lot of
ways it's just like I really wasn't I
wasn't going anywhere I didn't fit in
you never would have thought of me as
the the guy who's gonna the most
ambitious the most you know but did you
feel like you there was something inside
of you that wanted something different
so something more than Waco something
more than just like you felt like
innately there was something inside of
you that wanted more
um I always knew I wasn't going to stay
stay in a small town I always wanted to
travel my dad knew that I wanted to act
and it was my senior year and they were
um there was a local band that was
casting for their first music video and
they wanted it to be there in their
hometown
and um
my Dad read about it in the paper and
said they're doing open casting calls if
you want to go so I went and I got what
was considered I guess a featured extra
and
um and the uh oddly enough the director
was Antoine Fuqua
what this was before he had done like
training day and everything
[__] project yeah
and the producer was from propaganda
films wow and he and I just got to
talking and I told him you know that
acting is what I wanted to do and for
some reason he kept saying well have you
ever modeled because if you come to New
York over your senior Christmas break
I'll take you to some agencies see some
photographers
and I never really wanted to model but I
thought about it and models at that time
models did commercials and actors did
commercials so I was like hmm maybe it's
a way for me to get into acting
so my parents he came and talked to my
parents they actually agreed to it
because they were like he was actually a
really nice guy and he didn't ask for
money he wasn't asking for anything he
was offering to help
and so we went over Christmas and I got
signed to an agency the light goes again
what agency
it was called Cameo
um a small agency but
um really great people
and nine days after I graduated I moved
to New York
so that's crazy my trajectory it was
always going to be like when I could
leave I was just gonna start my life
were your parents nervous for you were
they like oh I don't know New York
you're going from Waco Texas to New York
City to be a model you're like what 17
18 17 yeah and who are you gonna live
with Where Are You Gonna Go I mean what
I mean that's a big trip
so we stayed in NYU housing so all the
NYU housing over the summer were for
interns and models and whoever you know
was coming in town for the summer and
that's the housing that the modeling
agency was using
so it was cool because I mean I met
people from all over that came in just
for the summer so I became friends with
people that lived in LA and people that
are writers now big writers in Hollywood
that were there from Michigan and it was
really cool my mom took me and got me
settled and left me there and yeah I
never looked back it was amazing so did
you feel like what was it was it did you
suddenly feel like hey I think I found
I this is I fit in here
no no I definitely I definitely didn't
fit in I was always struggling
um and I was always like at first when
you first go there as a young model they
all the girls they Chopped all our hair
off and we all looked the same and then
we were going to all these auditions and
we all look the same I'm like I don't
even understand like and I hated the way
like they had done my hair but you
didn't have a choice at that point
and I I was doing it because my parents
said look we've put money aside for you
for college but if you want to use it on
this instead you can but when it's gone
it's gone then you have to come home so
like okay well I can't let that happen
um but they never wanted me to resent
them if they had said no and always look
back and wonder what if you yeah so
that's why they let me do it because
they they knew that I could always go to
college later right and this opportunity
was now
so I was very homesick for a long time
and I traveled a lot doing it but
it it's not like when you travel now
when you're older and you you have a bit
more money where you can explore and you
would travel places above ground versus
below ground yeah you know like when you
have no money you're always traveling
underground so you're not seeing
anything and I wasn't into the culture
of different countries yet you know I
wasn't I was just there to try to work
and make money so I didn't have to go
home right you know and that's that was
my whole goal was to just do well enough
that I could make money break even not
have to go home like and and figure out
something else right what was your first
Big Break as a model that you were like
oh my God I got this or a commercial
what was it that you're gonna make some
money my break well you know listen when
you're doing nothing and you're coming
out of high school and you start doing
things a Burger King commercial could be
the biggest break you've had or
anybody's had
you know it's funny because the first I
think printed something in print in a
magazine that I did was for
um menstrual cramps oh well there you go
yeah from menstrual cramps it was just
me drinking a thing of water in an
outfit like I'd been working out but it
was for cramps I was like yeah how many
was it a commercial or just print
no it was a print ad yeah and did it pay
pretty well like back then what was it
like what did you get paid for a print
ad like that 500 a thousand bucks
I mean maybe I mean print ads back then
I mean I don't know what it's like now
but throughout my whole modeling career
the printed magazine things didn't pay
well what paid well were catalogs the
things that like JCPenney cattle yeah
you know newspaper catalog or their big
main catalog that's where the money was
Bloomingdale's yeah Dillards things like
that let me ask you quickly did you send
a copy of the menstrual cramps print to
your parents and say look I made it
yeah I'm sure
I'm excited yeah but they were still
excited for you
see my family my parents I remember I
was in New York and I go hey I got this
movie and they're like what is it yeah I
go yeah it's this independent movie like
well so it's not a real movie no it's
independent well what does that mean is
it a who who's in it well no oh [__] I'm
a failure yeah there was no excitement
which is great like we're so excited to
book a job yeah they never works as
excited until like I got something big
that they go oh I I okay I know that
that's a network that's real okay uh you
know but so what was the the biggest
thing the one that kind of puts you on
the map that you were like holy [__] for
for modeling or what was it what was
your first Big Break
I don't think I ever was on the map for
modeling to be honest
um I when I went to LA I my plan was to
drive to LA
and drive cross-country hitting all the
major modeling markets for catalog and
building up my money and then my plan
was to go back to LA and start taking
acting classes so I wanted I didn't
think I was ready to go
conquer La yet so I went there to visit
a couple friends that I had made in the
beginning and including that producer he
was in LA now and
um I've visited a few people in my
agency in Dallas said well look while
you're there
go see some photographers get some
pictures done they have the best
photographers there go see an agency
so I did and I signed I think I was with
Ford first so I signed with Ford in La
that's a big one
I yeah somehow eventually I got with
Ford and with Elite at different times
right and I don't know how I did that
but I definitely wasn't one of their top
models I think I just made enough to get
by yeah but
um I did some I did some auditions while
I was there and I booked a commercial
and I'm like okay that's good and then I
booked another commercial and they had
to Taft Hartley me to get my sidecar
tell everybody what Taft Hartley is
um gosh I barely remember I somebody has
to sponsor you when it's a union
commercial and you've done I think the
first one you can get by with not being
Union but the second one somebody has to
sponsor you to get into the Union right
and it's one of the the best ways to get
in the union because it can be quite
hard to get in otherwise
and so because I had booked two
commercials that were both
um Union I got in the union and so my
whole plan of like the crossover model
actor thing was starting to fall into
place so I never left La did you think
that you were
like when you were growing up did you
think I'm just going to live in a small
town I know you said you want to get
away but was there part of you that kind
of like
it was like that feeling like I want to
get married I want to have kids I don't
want to do this this is too much oh
you're shaking your head you never
thought that you were always ambitious
I never I was never the kind that wanted
to have kids I never
thought about like a family or anything
because that would slow down my own
Ambitions I was always very much about
I have goals I have dreams and and
nothing could throw me off of that right
did your parents say anything did your
parents like did your parents ever go
you know I'd love you to get married
have a family because my grandma still
does that you know I think they learned
early on because I always said I was
never having kids I think they realized
that I wasn't lying right right
so they they never really pushed me so
they knew that all my dogs were their
grandkids there you go there you go and
a rhino now
and a rhino
um all right so you're in La now you're
booking commercials things are starting
to go for you you're taking acting
classes you're getting better and better
by the way the print stuff did you ever
feel really comfortable did you have it
down or you like I just want to get out
of this I don't really feel comfortable
I felt comfortable with catalog but only
after I went to Taiwan oddly enough
I I remember going to Taiwan and not
having a clue what was going on and the
first day they sent like 10 of us out we
were all staying in a house together and
every place you go to you have to put on
their clothes and you have to hit a post
or a bunch of poses like as if you were
doing a catalog and I didn't know what
that meant I didn't know what it was and
I was in tears by the end of the day and
one of the girls that had been there a
bunch of times she said look it's like a
dance she she taught me like five or six
poses and she said all you have to do is
hit them and then start again just cycle
through them and once I got that I was
booking left and right I'm like okay
that I can do and so then I started
booking and I was very happy to just do
that kind of stuff because
I I've never had that look of that you
know that that hard seductive European
look where if you don't smile you look
sexy like yeah I have to smile like I'm
the smiley girl which is I know that I
know that we all do we've all done that
we're taking pictures for a movie
premiere or we're at the Globes or
wherever the hell you are and they start
taking pictures and you go from like
kind of like natural smile to like um
I sometimes just close my mouth because
I look like a goofball smiling but I
just kind of go um
there's pictures of me out there not
smiling because I don't like the way I
look not smiling really well you have a
great smile if you Google me almost
every picture is smiling and almost
every picture is my left side by the way
were you constantly as a model and young
going out in New York going to Taiwan in
L.A were you I mean it's a stupid
question because I know what you're
gonna say but were you constantly hit on
guys constantly hitting on you
no come on
I I think I was quite awkward I was very
shy I'm still very shy like
an outgoing person I have to try and
it's only it's actually because of
modeling that I started learning that I
had to try because it was when I was in
Dallas I was in a modeling house and
maybe a couple weeks in I went out with
a bunch of the the models there like we
I just remember we were in the car we
were having fun and we came home and we
were chatting and they were like you
know we thought you were such a [__]
but you could like you you just sat
around and you didn't like talk to us or
anything I was like but I was really
scared I was shy you guys were all
friends and I just got there and they're
like yeah but you know you weren't
talking to us so we didn't like you but
now we do and I'm like okay so now
lesson learned I have to try to come out
of my shell quicker so that that
perception isn't out there because that
wasn't my intention I was just scared
you know what I get it I remember the
first time meeting you and just like
throughout the years after I sort of
knew you and I just remember
I was like oh she you're just you were
just you you weren't necessarily trying
you're just you were polite but you you
didn't seem like you were like hey how's
it going I'm I'm nice you should like me
you were just you but that's kind of who
you are you are sort of a shy person you
are sort of and I thought my because I'm
insecure as [__] my first thought was
she doesn't like me at all
and then as I talk to you I got to know
you a little more I was like oh wait a
minute I think she thinks I'm okay I
don't you know I don't and it just but
it took him you're not that kind of
person that just immediately goes to
somebody and people are like oh I love
her I love her right away you don't you
don't put that on it's you know and I
like that about you I have to turn it on
I have to really consciously be in a
space where I'm like okay I'm on I'm
gonna talk to everybody and I'm not
gonna be shy and and once in a while I
can do it but generally it's just not me
I have to build up to it you know and a
lot of people that I've become friends
with are that kind of person and that's
how we became friends because I'm
standing in the corner not talking to
anybody and they're like Hi how are you
what's going on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know I think I'm short of that
person so that's how I became friends
first with Mila because Mila is like
that she was always this young vibrant
like hey what's going on and our
dressing rooms were next to each other
she would always come over and talk to
me and I loved it but Mila from 70s Show
Mila Kunis yes yeah
so she's like that she's very personable
and very open yeah you know really she
used to be I mean I don't know I haven't
seen her in a while but that's what
broke the ice for me on on that show was
her being so bouncy and like fun you
know so she made you feel comfortable
she was really sweet
yeah isn't that nice when you hear that
about people when you when you find out
oh you know if they were good to other
people they were good to guess Stars
they were good to because you were a
recurring character on That 70s Show
season what
seven or eight season seven right by the
way Ryan and I Ryan's my engineer who
you can't see here who's my my cohort
we're it's similar I'm sort of the hey
how you doing you know want everybody to
have a good time and Ryan's really nice
guy but he's kind of like subdued a
little bit he's a little bit chill he's
like you know he's not gonna go up to
you and go hey man what's your name
where you from you know he's not that
guy you know that's so similar uh so
what was the first big acting thing what
was the the big one that that you're
like hey oh my gosh this isn't just
commercials this isn't just print I'm
acting now
well the first
pretty decent role that I had was on a
show called arless I remember before
this good show you remember he's great
Robert on HBO yeah
and I played a Russian tennis player
actually really
it was one of those things where
I I was I think I was always that girl
that if you can't find anyone else I was
good enough that I could come in and
like book it because they were out of
options
and I think that's why I got it yeah me
too because
my um I remember my agency going okay
they need somebody who can act who can
wear a bathing suit because you have to
swim
that could play tennis and I played
competitive tennis growing up and that
could do this accent and so because I'd
never really done an accent what I
decided to do and I don't know for
someone who's shy I don't know where I
found it within me to do this but
because they needed somebody to start
like the next day
um I went in there and I didn't want
them to judge my accent so I went in
there only speaking the accent saying
this was my real accent
like my I my parents were what was it
just talk to me like this or is it the
best you can remember
it's like you know like no you know my
parents they talk like this at home so
this is how I talk I don't really I mean
I know I've been living here a long time
but I just talked like this and they're
like great you talk like that we don't
have to think about your accent so you
think that's why I got it because they
didn't realize till I was in wardrobe
fittings the next day when I finally
dropped it they were like oh you don't
actually have next oh my gosh that's
ballsy
I know I don't know where I found it
within me to do it but I did but you
planned on it before you went in there
you're like I'm going to talk like this
and I'm going to make them love me and
I'm play tennis and everything's great
yeah and it was great I mean there were
so many because I think if you remember
the show there were always so many great
guest stars on the show
um John Mcenroe I think I played tennis
with John Mcenroe on the show what Zappa
was my boyfriend at the end I think of
the episode or something so there were
like so many cool people I think John
Sally might have been in the episode as
well I haven't seen it in so long but it
was that was the first thing where I had
enough to do throughout the whole
episode that I used that as my reel I
stopped trying to put a reel together
and I just gave that episode to people
as my real and it worked
and it works and you started booking
[__]
well I gotta because of it I got a
better like agent and manager and with
the manager I had he was he was friends
he had gone to college with my ex
at the time the the who I was with at
the time right and
um and he was doing him a favor to let
me come in and talk to him so I went in
and I chatted with them and I left him
this
um VHS of my
ages us a VHS came oh perfect perfect
but he's like I take 10 percent
on everything you do including modeling
and I got up to leave I was like nope
because I've been doing that for a long
time without you you're not touching it
and he's like well that's what I take I
go okay see you later and I let and I
got up and left and as I got to the door
he stopped me are you serious you had
the balls to get up and just say no no
you got up and left
yeah I mean I've been modeling for so
long on my own and I have a modeling
agency that takes 20 so why am I giving
this guy another 10. good for you that
makes sense so 30 gone plus taxes no so
he stopped you and goes okay fine
five percent yeah
you said no nothing nothing off the
model you might have even tried to say
15 at the time and I said no because I
know the going rate's 10. right I'm not
doing it so he took you on people back
then would do that right it was always
15 they took 15 your agent would take 10
your lawyer would take five percent
taxes were like 30 or 40 percent I mean
you were left you know you make a
hundred thousand dollars which is a lot
of money you get like 40.
yeah people think you know this guy
makes 20 million dollars he makes nine
still a lot of money but it's not 20. so
it is um so he took you on he says okay
I'm gonna take you on then how soon
after were you were you booked in
something I mean I did I don't
so I gosh I can't remember the order of
things of what I did with him or versus
other right other people I mean I did
for a while I did a bunch of those
um like Saturday morning kids shows like
um the Saved by the Bell type of things
that were I don't remember the names of
all of them but I did a guest stars on a
bunch of those
but it was probably within the year or
two that I got American Pie now was
American Pie the same sort of thing
where you go I'm gonna go in with an
accent I'm gonna think they I want them
to think I talk like this
no no I
I don't remember exactly what I did but
I do remember that the casting director
came over to me and he's like look I'm
gonna call you back for the directors
but you got to work on your accent
because I mean look I'm not saying this
he said this I don't know if it's not PC
but he is like try not to sound deaf
because that's how I sounded doing the
accent to him that's what he said to you
so you went home and you go well how do
I not okay
and you just worked on it
yeah I I don't I don't remember how I
worked on it after that I think I worked
with a few different dialect coaches
um I just don't remember at what point
how much time did you have to prepare
the second time around
I don't remember just not not a long
time you had to work fast
is it something yeah is it something you
could just jump into like you jumped
into the Russian can you just jump into
that accent now
I mean it's the same accent pretty much
is it pretty much the same
it was Czechoslovakian so yeah I pretty
much did the same accent but like what
had happened I was in an acting class
and so you you know Joe my ex yes
okay are you guys still friendly are you
still friendly he's he's actually
managing me he's helping manage me while
I'm here so yeah beautiful what a rarity
what a rare thing in Hollywood an
ex-husband manages his ex-wife good for
you guys
yeah that's cool man because I know it
wasn't easy in the beginning after the
breakup it was like there's a lot of
distance for a while
for two years for two years
yeah and then we found our way back to
being friends and and now like we we
help each other so yeah it's beautiful
yeah he's a great guy
um but he he and I were in an acting
class together and there at one point
there was a scene I was trying to do
from Pulp Fiction and I was trying to do
French and I can't do a French accent
and he said remember when class when you
tried to do French do that accent
because it sounded Russian like oh okay
it's just one of those accents that is
easier for me like everybody has an
accent that they can just like fake I
guess and for some reason that's just
one of them that I could sort of do but
with that said when I when I did
American Pie
um they called me in to do ADR which is
all the voiceover stuff after after
you've filmed and they're like we're
gonna play with the accent a bit and so
I'd say something and they're like okay
now do less of an accent and I'd say it
again they're like do less I'm like why
why are they messing with this accent so
much because I had worked really hard
with like a dialect coach on this
and so then I they said say things like
you've been here for a long time
so then I would say it and they're like
yeah that's it I go but I took the
accident off on that one like there was
no accident left
so after the ADR session I told all my
friends this movie is gonna suck because
they had messed with my accent so much I
was like no they're they're ruining it
the movie's gonna suck like don't watch
it I was like I was devastated after ADR
no
so and yeah so when you saw what they
had done what you'd put back into it
when you adr'd all this [__] you went
back did you go back in again when was
the first time you saw her did you go to
the premiere and going I don't know what
I'm gonna say
so were you doing what I did yeah were
you doing what I would do is telling
everybody look I'm sorry I'm probably
gonna suck on this I'm probably my
accent's terrible just don't judge me
you weren't thinking this was gonna do
anything I could say my accent was
terrible and I'm like well yeah because
they messed with it they didn't let me
do it I wanted to do you know what's
funny is I remember I've seen it and I I
honestly I'm not saying this because
you're here I loved it
I loved it I really did I thought I
remember saying wow that's hilarious
she's hilarious oh my God I didn't think
unless you speak this language or you
most people don't the world that they
watch and they just say oh they oh she
has an accent they don't think too much
about things I wasn't thinking where is
she from exactly I just was like oh this
is fun
so cool thank you I swear to God me I
drop dead that's how I felt
but this when you saw the movie did you
say wow I'm part of something that's
going to be huge
um no
I didn't know like it was nobody knew it
was going to be huge
but
I mean there there were moments of
things happening around us where we
could see they were trying to
expand because my character was not
meant to be a main character I wasn't in
the original poster but they they I was
testing well and so they were expanding
my my presence
um and they were starting to include me
in a lot of the the
um magazine press and stuff that that
people were getting and
sorry my light is giving me something so
you were stealing the show in a lot of
ways I don't know about that whatever
but you know you were a likable
character was testing well and they kept
bringing you for and by the way you
probably got paid [__] for the movie The
First One
yeah do you remember going oh my God
this is what they're paying me no I I
didn't care they I would have done it
for free it was my first Studio film
so I was so happy to book a role in a
studio film like who cares about money
that's that's great that they're giving
me something for it
but then the second one comes and then
you're like okay you're like I'm making
some money this time it's the second one
I'll get paid did you ever almost walk
away because they're like well her
part's not as big as the others I'm sure
they tried to uh you know we're not
gonna pay her as much or did you put
your foot down and go hey man I'm
getting ready yeah many times I walked
away from a lot of offers really
my my lawyer and my
manager and agent they all thought I was
crazy and I kept saying no and they were
pushing me to say yes and I was like um
really just like you did with that
manager you got up and you walked the
[__] out I I just kept saying no they
would bring me things I was like I just
I don't know why I I guess I had a
number in my head I knew what I felt
like they should pay and we got them to
that number and then my team was very
excited that I said no all the other
times yeah right
but because I didn't get paid on the
first one hardly like I think it was
something like
a couple thousand I don't know it wasn't
a lot and
it was it was nothing and strike when
the Iron's hot strike when the Iron's
hot you're like yeah you know you get
like 15 minutes so you got to milk it
absolutely you never know this could be
it I'm done and if you got it you gotta
get what you can from it because they're
gonna take everything from you they're
gonna try and give you as little as
possible that is just the way it works
well and I think every actor as soon as
they're done with a role if they don't
have another one lined up they think
that's it I'm never gonna book another
role like I would always have this
anxiety when I would rap a movie if I
didn't have something else booked then
like I'm never gonna work again what's
you know and it you kind of like freak
out and you don't that's just part of
being an actor I think it's just part
all my friends said that they had that
feeling what was your what's the the
biggest thing or your favorite role
you've done besides American Pie what
role did you really just have fun and go
I love doing this
they're a couple I mean I I loved
playing Buffy and scary movie that was
really fun
um like especially like when I got to do
my my death scene because Keenan Ivory
Wayans really worked with me on it for a
long time we shot take after take after
take after take
so that was fun and and it was one of
the only times we got to do rehearsals
like to be on a film where you get to
have a week in rehearsals to get to like
know each other and bond and like it's
such a great experience to have that
yeah
um and then there was another film that
is just a little Hallmark film called
catch a Christmas star and I got to play
kind of like a a pop star that
goes back home and falls in love with
like the high school boyfriend kind of
thing and it was just very sweet but I
got to sing and I'd never gotten to sing
in a movie and to go in studio and
record songs was just really really fun
and because I was a pop star they always
had like the most beautiful hair and
makeup on me and glitter and like I just
had such a great team and and we shot
the whole thing in like 12 days it was
so quick but it was one of the best
experiences it's amazing you say it's it
amazes me when I hear this because I
miss that element you say how much fun
you had I went to the studio and I sang
and I never got to do this and it was so
fun and to me that gives me anxiety
thinking about going in and singing and
doing it just everything is just like I
gotta be great I gotta I gotta you know
and you didn't feel like that you were
actually having a good time
well I was in choir when I was in school
and I loved choir but I was never the
greatest singer I was never the one that
got the solos but I was I was good
enough to make like the main choir group
if if that's what it was called right
so I was just I was okay but I would get
such nerves like I I would
audibly sound nervous when I would sing
if I was trying to sing on my own or do
a solo or something like I didn't know
how to control the nerves
but to be able to then take that and go
into a studio and work with people and
really like keep singing lines until you
get it just right and I don't know I
love it I think it's so much fun I mean
I think there's every actor wants to be
a musician every musician wants to be an
actor so it kind of fulfilled some of
that for me was it have you ever had
debilitating anxiety or anything that
caused like really hindered you from
being at your best or do you remember
ever being on set or just did anxiety
ever get in your way the depression or
anything getting your way over the years
yeah
yeah no definitely
um I think
I think everybody goes through stuff
like that I mean anxiety not on on set
per se but
um
it it depends there's there's different
versions of it I mean there were things
that would happen on said where it was
kind of like a throwback to high school
where I just didn't feel like I fit in I
mean I remember being on one set where
there was a bunch of girls and all the
girls smoked but me and so they would
all go outside and smoke all the time
and I didn't fit in because I didn't go
do that
and I didn't want to be out there
because I didn't want to breathe in the
smoke
but I didn't know how to bond with them
you know what was it what show was it or
you don't want to say I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna say which one all right well
you didn't say anything bad about the
girls you just said you didn't fit in
I didn't fit in
I didn't fit in but
um yeah so I I would get that kind of
anxiety right
um and I I did a movie
um
and Henry Winkler was on there and I had
made a comment about
not not being good enough or not fitting
in with them or something because there
was there were all these Tom Arnold was
there there were all these great actors
around and on and then I I don't know
how I got there and I just remember
Henry Winkler made me go home he goes in
the mirror that you look in every day
you're gonna write in lipstick and and
now I've forgotten exactly what it was
but it was something like I am good
enough
something to that degree and so he told
me to do that and so I went home and did
that and I always thought of him he is
such a man she still texts me Michael
how are you I hope you and your brother
are great how's the dog I love you
Shannon I want you to write in lipstick
I am good enough and I love you Shannon
he is the best and by the way I've been
doing hypnotherapy and they're it's
amazing how when you rewire your brain
and you and you bring confidence and
repetitive confirmation like what's the
word uh
affirmation affirmations yeah to you
then you you change the way your brain
thinks because if you're like oh I know
I can't do it um I'm gonna have anxiety
I'm gonna have but if you start going
I'm confident I can do this I it's
amazing that the brain could reprogram
itself and it's starting to work for me
a little bit I've noticed it you got to
just you know in the same vein have you
ever tried microdosing everybody's been
telling me that Theo Rossi from Sons of
Anarchy uh many many people I'm going to
try it I'm going to do it
um
there's a conference I'm actually
talking to the founder tomorrow it's
called microdosing uh it's a conference
in Florida that I think it's a in Miami
that's about to take place and the
speakers if you go I think it's
microdosing.com if you go look at the
speakers they have I mean I remember
meeting with Kevin Harrington from Shark
Tank yeah way back way back in the day
when he was on Shark Tank and now he's a
speaker at this conference and to see
the trajectory of some of these amazing
entrepreneurs that are now believing in
microdosing I think it's quite
fascinating do you microdose you know I
I have but part of what I want to talk
to him about is that the the times that
I have more than anything it makes me
very sleepy and I know it's not supposed
to do that yeah and I want to know if
it's my chemical makeup or like what
some people have said is well maybe it's
what you need and you're getting from
the medicine what you need and you need
to rest
so but I I don't know I mean I've I've
tried a few different micro dosing type
things
um but I but then I'll see my husband
will do it and he gets that feeling
where your mind is quite expanded and
and he feels calm
where's the feeling I'm getting is just
it literally puts me to sleep
so maybe it's too high I want the Mind
expansion you know and I want the the
groundedness and and everything you're
you know you're talking about
um with the hypnotherapy because even
that like I I would love to do that
um I have a great person she's really
great and I was doubting it and I was
just in and all of a sudden I start
listening to these this 20 minutes at
night 20 minutes in the morning every
day and it becomes a habit and things
have changed a little bit for me I mean
it's still new but it's working I have
to say it's working I get frustrated
sometimes I don't want to do it
sometimes but yeah anyway look you've
had a great career I mean you've done so
many things
um but your whole you really transition
because next time I talk to you we'll
get into the poker plane because you're
like an unbelievable poker player you're
like the best celebrity poker player
there is and uh probably one of the best
poker players out there
you've won money what's the most money
you've won 55 000. 100 000 100 a hundred
and twenty five thousand when I did the
NBC heads up Championship 25
000.
she's the real deal I mean you are a
poker player bum though because I should
have gone to the finals but I was so
upset how much would you have won if you
went to the finals
I don't remember
mix level is probably 250 and 500 for
first and second if I got 125 it must
have been something like that good Lord
but I I played I was playing against
Paul wassaka who went on to win it right
and Paul was like look it really didn't
matter what hand you picked I was he was
just getting good hands he said every
hand I got all of a sudden was just so
good it didn't matter wow uh I was so
bummed but I was really practicing
um the secret then this was when the
secret was big yeah and I started really
vigorously practicing that and
envisioning and manifesting like
the outcome and the wins that works you
really think it worked
if you commit yourself to it and you
believe it
it can work I mean it's manifestation
um the secret just took it from many
other people who've taught it way before
that and they kind of did their own
thing with it but it it's manifestation
in fact when I got scary movie it I
didn't know at the time that I was
manifesting but there's a woman in La
that I would buy like these little oils
and candles and stuff from and I had
mentioned to her that I had had this
audition and I really wanted this role
and so she had told me go home and sit
and and just imagine what it feels like
when you get the call that you get the
role imagine feeling in your body the
excitement and who you're gonna call and
what you're going to tell them and she
went through this whole thing and I was
like okay okay I'm gonna do that and I
really did it and I did it all the time
and from the time I first auditioned to
the time I got the role there was four
months in between because they had gone
across the country looking like for the
people for these roles and the whole
time I was just sitting there trying to
manifest because they wanted to give me
a different role and I was like no I
want puffy I don't want another roll I
want Buffy
but Buffy was supposed to be blonde and
so Keenan didn't really want me because
he wanted a blonde but then the the lead
role was supposed to be a brunette so he
just swapped us around in the end but
that was the first time I had worked on
manifestation but I didn't know it was
called that I didn't know what I was
doing
Ryan we might have to try some
manifestation my brother
some affirmations and some
manifestations
uh look we're running out of time here
but uh we can go a little bit over
um let's get into the non-profit let's
get into the Shannon Elizabeth
Foundation Moon of the Rhino first of
all when did it occur to you that this
is what I need to do like when did
you're like I know what I want to do
and I want to move to Africa and I want
to do this well I mean whatever it is
when did that happen and and you know
so when I when I did American Pie it was
the first time I was in a position to
give back and long story short I just
realized I wanted to start my own animal
rescue so I started a dog and cat rescue
called animal Avengers ran it that way
for over 10 years and then knew I wanted
to help more animals on a bigger scale
and went on this long quest to figure
out what that was I didn't know how to
revamp the charity but I wanted to do
something else with it and through my
own process of figuring myself out
um I was I had sold my house in La I was
looking for another place and then just
realized I didn't want to be in La
anymore went to New York and when I was
in New York I started somehow paying a
lot of attention to conservation
organizations and there was a an ivory
and Rhino Horn uh Crush in Times Square
that I got invited to and I met a bunch
of conservationists there
and started following everyone online
and there was one video that I came
across like literally I was getting
ready to go to dinner I was doing my
makeup and something said check
Instagram
and I didn't know what I was checking
for but I was scrolling on Instagram and
I came across this video of an elephant
that had been poached and the ranger was
filming as he was walking and saying
this poor baby's been out here all night
suffering and as you see it's you saw
her trunk off to one side and then you
saw her face and then she moved
and that hit me like a ton of bricks the
fact that she was still alive
and this had happened to her and I never
till that moment realized that these
animals were getting
their their Ivory and their horns taken
off while they were alive and they were
feeling every cut
and that that's what changed it for me
and that was that was
2014. I just felt that didn't you
she's just you explaining that to me I
just like felt it
it
changed me I I the whole night I was
thinking about I was trying not to cry
at dinner I I couldn't get out of my
mind and I said that's what I want to do
with the charity the fact that these
animals these big Majestic animals like
elephants could go extinct in our
lifetime and we're we're here doing
nothing like it doesn't make sense like
we all got to go see an elephant or a
rhino at some point maybe when we were
younger or anywhere
you know that they're on the planet with
you but then to leave the planet one day
and they're not there anymore that's
that that didn't compute with me so I
started going to South Africa to learn
and to understand what the issue was and
try to find ways I could help and make a
difference and
in the process just decided I was going
to move here and spend more time here
and and uh I ended up getting married
and we revamped the charity to be the
Shan Elizabeth foundation for now it'll
change eventually soon hopefully
um but now we we have a blind black
rhino that we take care of we just built
a sanctuary forum
yeah and uh we're gonna bring some
females over so he can breed he's
already he's already doing this thing
where I've realized that he's checking
for female pheromones to see if they're
around so I know he's ready for it and
and we're filming it all to be a
docu-series so
at this point we we just we need more
funding we need to up the security to
bring the females over we we have more
parts of the sanctuary we need to do and
we're talking to different broadcast
partners for the for the docusary so
it's the the first time I'm really
bringing my two worlds together and
um I'm I'm directing it but I'm gonna
co-direct it I'm actually
I I'm actually looking for the right
co-director to do the rest of it with me
I have some ideas so
uh I think that's unbelievable I commend
you uh I I I I'm gonna donate right
after we get off again all right so
where where can we go to donate I'm I'm
serious guys this is this is
unbelievable
um if you go to Shannon elizabeth.org
munu
m-a-m-a-n-u-m-a-n-u m-u-m-u
m-u-n-u
yes m-u-n-u munu
um there you'll see a video that we've
done that's like a five minute Sizzle
kind of trailer of the the show and and
the conservation work that we're doing
we figured if we're doing the work
anyway we might as well film it and tell
the story to the world because most most
Rhino stories are about death and
they're gruesome and people don't don't
want to see
um another picture of an animal with
their face cut off but this is a story
of love and hope and courage and and
Trust because he's trusting us because
he can't see and we you know we were
able to move him to this place and we
we've built something that we know he's
kind of familiar with but it's got a lot
more space for him a lot of trees to
browse and he trusts us to lead him
through it and
yeah we wanted to tell like a really
good story that that could inspire
people and so that's that's what we're
the mission we're on right now do you
think he knows you you're touching your
voice he knows my voice yeah he knows my
voice
um you can see how he reacts to his
different caretakers and people that are
around him for a long time and
um when he first came into the outdoor
area
um for the first time in the new
Sanctuary he was walking around he
walked right in front of me and started
vocalizing which was just like an
amazing thing if you've never heard a
rhino vocalize it's just it melts your
heart that's beautiful so well good for
you yeah good for the organization big
project right now I love that all right
this is really quick this is uh [__]
talking with Shannon Elizabeth these are
my top tier patrons uh they make the
show possible all my patrons do without
them I don't know what I would do uh go
to patreon.com inside of you uh once you
join I will send you a message back
these are rapid fire fiery answer
quickly ready little Lisa little Lisa do
you have any funny behind the scenes
moments you could please share when you
were filming Jay and Silent Bob Strike
Back or Jay and Silent Bob reboot thank
you yeah I'm not getting quick buyer
there aren't a lot of like
like funny moments like that that I can
think of I mean obviously Jason Muse is
always is always joking around and
having fun but I can't think of any one
thing I'm sorry all right that's all
right Leanne very impressed with the
work your foundation does on behalf of
wildlife conservation what was the spark
that motivated you we just heard that we
just heard the spark we just heard the
sparkly end thank you uh Brett G if you
can go back in time is there anything
you would change or do differently in
your acting career I would ask for more
money for American Pie too
yeah I mean there are things I'm not
going to go into specifics but I'll say
that when you're
when you're a woman that stands up for
herself when asked to do things you
don't want to do that can be perceived
wrong and
there's a process of doing it that that
is better than doing it yourself
like I would stand up for myself too
much versus letting my manager do that
so yeah I probably would go back and
like let my team fight for me more
rather than me saying I'm not going to
do that let them look like the [__]
yeah let them yeah uh okay Kelly s who'd
you get closest with in American Pie and
are you close with anybody from the cast
still
I got closest at the time I got closest
with Mina Mina would always do girls
girls nights and girls lunches and stuff
so I was hanging out with her the most
um and I do still see her and Tara
probably the most oh and um
and Thomas and Nicholas because we all
do autograph signings we have the same
management so we'll go do autograph
signings in different areas sometimes in
different countries so it's a lot of fun
to travel and do that that's awesome
Jennifer Ann seeing you in 13 Ghosts
what was it like to work with Matthew
Lillard and Tony Shalhoub Tony shalu is
like my hero He is unbelievable and you
know he played my Dad we're both
Lebanese which I loved and
um he he really treated me like like an
equal that I didn't feel like I deserved
that but like I remember we we would fly
back and forth to Vancouver and we would
talk about the storyline and things we
wanted to pitch to the director that
might change things slightly and so he
would sit there next to me on the plane
and be like okay what about this and
what about that okay I'm gonna take it
to him and see what he says and I was
just to me just to be able to do that
was amazing I loved so so much that's
awesome and Matthew is just such a funny
fun nice guy I had actually worked with
Matthew before on a film called dish
dogs with he and
um Sean Aston that was actually one of
my first films
um they're both Menches I love both of
those guys Sean Aston is probably the
nicest guy there is next to Henry
Winkler nicest guy in the world
absolutely Billy yes last question
besides acting what are some things you
would like to work on besides uh the
Shannon Elizabeth foundation and acting
is there anything else you want to play
some more tennis with me maybe I play
tennis
now I really want to work on directing
and producing I'm being more behind the
camera all right to be able to shape the
stories in that way it's it's really the
the direction I want to be going more
than being in front of the camera so as
much as possible I'm jumping behind uh I
think it's awesome uh what's your
Instagram so people could follow you and
they can go donate
what is your answer my Instagram is at
Shannon Elizabeth
at Shannon Elizabeth that's it
that's it and can you do me a favor and
tell Simon I'm thinking about him and I
hope his forearm's okay
I will I will he told me to tell you hi
he didn't know if you'd remember I do
remember him I do remember him he
remembers you as such a great guy well
well his memory's a little bit uh off
but uh no not at all this has been a
treat I know it's late for you it's a
little later than we normally do this
but I appreciate you doing this I've
always wanted to talk to you and I know
you live out there but continue the
great work it's just really stunning
you're a beautiful person inside and out
and the world needs more of you and
um yeah I think I really appreciate you
and I'll let you know when this comes
out and uh I love you
I love you too thank you so much thanks
for having me on and giving me the
platform to to talk about things that I
love like munu we all love munu go down
all right I'll see you later all right
thank you bye
[Music]
uh thank you for listening to Shannon
Elizabeth
um I don't get to see her much anymore
because she obviously she lives far away
but um she does make an impact I I look
up to people like that to someone who
really takes the time because time is
valuable it's invaluable
but to actually
take time from not doing anything and
relaxing to devoting most of your time
saving the world
saving animals saving exotic animals
saving help saving human beings I mean
I mean just to to know and decide that
that is your thing that you're going to
devote your time to that's your purpose
yeah what a great thing it would be to
know your purpose to really know this is
what why I'm here yeah because you know
a lot of times you gotta is my purpose
this is it should I be and you're just
lost and a lot of people that you know
my age 50 middle of midlife it's like
what's my purpose but when you know it
like my friend Shira for um the animal
rescue mission arm animal rescue mission
and I'm on the board of course I want to
know why sometimes I go blank but like
that's her Mission whether she likes it
or not she's always she gravitates
towards saving animals that's what she
does
and uh so I'm just like oh you know I
still want to act and I still want to
and I don't yeah I go whatever you do
your purpose is that though you get to
act because you love it you're good at
it whatever but your purpose it's nice
to know your purpose yeah and that's the
message for today thank you for
listening uh I love you thanks to all
the top tier patrons and the bottom tier
patrons and any Patron who signs up to
support the podcast whether it's one
cent or whatever
uh you're really really help us
patreon.com inside of you thank you for
the love and send me a message I'll
message you back let's do it let's do
the top tiers
okay all right you ready
go ahead yep what start yeah
who would be the first uh Nancy D Leah s
Trisha F Sarah
Yukiko little little Lisa
uh
it's good that you just remember off the
bat uh there's a uh yup Jason W Brian
there's a Brian uh yep
oh God H Brian H and Camp Jill E Yeah
Nico P Robert B that's the one I was
thinking of you are Sophie M Kristen K
rash C Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L
Jamal F Correctional B Kimberly
e Mike e l Don Supremo 99 or Santiago
um Chad W Leanne P Janine R Maya P
Maddie s Belinda and Chris H Dave H
Sheila G
um Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and
Liliana a Talia and Betsy D Chad L Dan n
big Stevie W angel
f
h a
M correct Rhiannon see Cory
Corey K Corey K Dev Nixon Michelle a
Jeremy C Brandy D Camille s
enek s-p-n-e-t-c
somebody make a mistake I like it though
hi snacked
Joey M Lee Eugene and Leah Corey Heather
L Jake B Megan T Angela F Mel s Orlando
C Caroline R Christine s Eric H shanar
Mr Andrew M zaroichi 77 Andreas n Oracle
Karina
don't know Anne Amanda R correct gen B
Kevin e Stephanie K Lena 82 Jarrell
Billy s jam and J Leanne J Luna R Cindy
e Mike F stoneh Brian L Cameron e Katie
B Aaron R Clayton J Kendall L House of
Joe L Joel was the house of jorel it
says House of Joe E House of Joe L
good Lord son maybe his name is Joe L or
her name is Joe yeah House of Joelle hi
Meredith l
hmm
Meredith I I think it is that's it those
are the top tiers thank you for all the
support and love you gonna say anything
else Ryan get anything else yeah no no
no one wants to know what I have to say
I do do you sure I got nothing I want to
play some dodgeball you wanna play some
dodgeball yeah that was a lot of fun I'm
not gonna play tonight but um yeah well
I want to play next time just ask me if
you need somebody I'll let you know when
when my friend who's the connection you
can go for free this uh this this West
Hollywood dodgeball I might I played in
a dodgeball tournament once it was the
Burt Reynolds classic and it was
everybody had to wear mustaches that's
fun it was fun I got my knot mustache
knocked the hell off my face though with
a dodgeball bro uh thanks for uh
listening uh from the Hollywood Hills in
Los Angeles I'm Michael Rosenbaum I'm
Ryan tayas Ryan TS a little wave to the
camera uh we love you guys thank you um
for listening and be good to yourself
I'll see you later
foreign